the House Lannister Targaryen Baratheon
stark Tyrell
they would respect tsunami its ones on
top and that
and on and on it's pinned
crushing what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
Season eight prediction video today I
want to talk about the inevitable battle
for King's Landing and I also want to
talk about the possibility of another
epic showdown on the bay a battle of the
Blackwater part two we know that with
this being the final season of Game of
Thrones they're going to produce some of
the greatest battle scenes in the
history of television
now that the tension is going to be at
an all-time high we're gonna see plenty
of action in and around King's Landing
the capital of Westeros is on the verge
of becoming a pile of rubble and I'm
going to tell you why there will be a
few spoilers in this video so please
proceed with caution when you're on
Greyjoy returns from Essos he is going
to have his ships parked right out in
the Blackwater Bay what do you think
Daenerys will do when she realizes
Cersei and Euron are strengthening their
position in King's Landing we all know
Cersei is never going to surrender and
this will eventually leave Daenerys no
choice but to strike King's Landing
Euron Greyjoy fleet would be the first
line of defense against an attack on the
city but those wooden ships don't stand
a chance against dragons that are the
size of 747 airplanes we saw just how
devastating these dragons could be
against stationary targets back in
Mereen so unless you're on or Qyburn
have some kind of an anti dragon weapon
it will be no different when she attacks
King's Landing Cersei Lannister still
has control over the Iron Throne but
it's only a matter of time before we see
her downfall or at least I hope so
I suppose Game of Thrones rarely ever
gives us what we truly want but I am
confident Circe's rain will come to an
end next season as we all know Daenerys
Targaryen is now in Westeros and she
plans on removing Cersei from power
Daenerys says she was born to rule the
Seven Kingdoms and she believes she will
the only problem is Cersei does not
intend on bending her knee in order for
Daenerys to take back the Seven Kingdoms
for House Targaryen she will need to
take down Cersei Lannister by force
which I believe we will see near the end
of the final season Daenerys was ready
to storm the city with her dragons in
season seven but her advisors suggested
otherwise way before season 7 ended
Daenerys found out firsthand that the
army of the Dead was real and she
already paid a man
of price by helping Jon Snow
unfortunately she lost one of her
dragons but this also proved that the
night king needed to be dealt with
immediately
so Daenerys and John were willing to
call a momentary truce with Cersei as
long as she agreed to help assist them
in the great war against the night king
but Cersei couldn't even do that
Cersei lied right to their faces by
saying she would help Daenerys and John
assume Cersei is sending all of her
banners north because that's what she
said in the dragon pit but then she told
Jaime she isn't sending a single soldier
to aid them in their fight against the
dead as soon as John and Daenerys
realized Circe's and sending them any
men this will only further motivate them
to go down to King's Landing as soon as
possible in Pride the Iron Throne from
her cold dead fingers
what makes this so interesting is the
fact that Jon and Daenerys will have to
use their forces against the night king
first because he is currently the
biggest threat to the entire realm in
order to stop the night king they will
need every swinging dick on the
battlefield fighting his army of the
dead and even that might not be enough
the reason why I say that is because by
the time Daenerys is ready to take down
Cersei she might not have enough
firepower to do this while Jon and
Daenerys are losing men in the north
Cersei will continue to get stronger in
the south now I know Cersei doesn't have
too many Lannister soldiers left not
after what Daenerys did to them on the
field of fire but she still has her own
Greyjoy and his iron fleet and he's
currently on his way to pick up the
golden company and they are 20,000
strong I also believe Chi burnstow knows
where plenty of wildfire is stored and
even if there isn't any more caches
under the city
Qyburn maybe having more made he was
secretly having ballistas made so I
wouldn't doubt if he was stockpiling
more wildfire for when the day comes
that they will need it even though
Daenerys currently still outnumbers
Cersei she may lose a large portion of
her army during the great war in the
north she could even lose more of her
dragons the night King killed maseri on
with one shot in ragel could fall just
as easily
drogon can be killed too but he will
most definitely live the longest because
he's the biggest and he has a writer I
actually think Daenerys and Jon will
lose most of their men against the night
king but as long as they still have
the Dragons they could at least barbecue
King's Landing and there are some
evidence of this already happening Game
of Thrones has already been filming
their final season for eight months the
war in the north is finished they spent
fifty five nights filming all of those
scenes but now they have moved their
attention to the south I have seen
enough photo and video evidence to know
King's Landing comes under attack and so
far there has been no sign of the army
of the Dead now they might be hiding
them very well but as of right now it
only appears to be Daenerys and John's
battle for the capital let's take a look
at some of the evidence that I'm
referring to I'm sure most of you have
seen this first video clip by now this
video was filmed about two weeks ago and
what you are looking at is the unsullied
in Dothraki lining up right outside of
King's Landing set in Belfast no it only
has Daenerys maybe the King's Landing
but a portion of her army is still
intact Daenerys and John should have
encountered the night King by now but
this is a good sign that he wasn't able
to kill all of their men at least not
yet that is
they had been filming at this King's
Landing set for almost a month and like
I said earlier there have been no signs
of the knight King or his army in this
location so I would like to think the
knight King has already been defeated by
the time they reach King's Landing again
but this is of course just a guess now
let's take a look at this new video clip
that just came out a few days ago this
one was posted on reddit and as you can
see there is a decent sized fire burning
in the city there is also a green screen
placed right behind the fire so they
will most likely add some sort of
effects to this scene they could also
change the colour of this fire during
post-production even though this appears
to be a normal fire they could always
change the colour to blue or green now
what I want to show you next is very
interesting because I believe this is
some good evidence that Dragons may have
attacked the capital if you take a look
at the photos on the screen you can see
that the King's Landing set has
sustained some significant damage they
spent over six months building this set
and it now appears to have been caught
on fire by someone or something the
reason why I think this was done by
dragons is the simple fact that only the
tops of the structures are burned which
most likely means the fire came from
above and not below we have known that
something like this could happen ever
since season two when Daenerys Targaryen
goes in
to the house of the undying she sees the
Great Hall and the Iron Throne and as
she is walking around she notices the
roof has been damaged by someone or
something I have always believed this
would be the caused by the Dragons
because only the rooftops appear to be
damaged I think we all knew it was only
a matter of time before Daenerys came to
King's Landing and attempted to remove
whoever is occupying the iron throne we
have also seen visions of this with
brain stark when brain was traveling to
the three-eyed Ravens cave he stops at a
weirwood tree beyond the wall and he
touches the tree then he sees several
different events taking place two of the
visions he has relates to this he has a
vision of a dragon flying over the
rooftops of King's Landing then he also
sees the throne room with the ceiling
burnt off in snow falling all over the
room and the Iron Throne
since brain and Daenerys saw the same
vision I have always thought that this
was a glimpse at something to come in a
future and now we finally have some
evidence of this possibly happening next
season we know Daenerys Targaryen czar
me was located right outside of the city
gates and now we know the city will burn
when you put two and two together it's
pretty easy to imagine what is going to
happen in these scenes now I haven't
seen any evidence of your own Greyjoy
being involved in this battle as of yet
but if he happens to be in King's
Landing when this battle takes place
then I can only assume his fleet will be
at anchor in the Blackwater Bay since he
is bringing Cersei the golden company he
might still be here at the end of the
season that's if Theon hasn't already
managed to kill him somehow for taking
his sister prisoner there was a report
that came out months ago that said Theon
and Yara were filming scenes together
inside of a studio in Belfast but there
wasn't any photo or video evidence to
prove it I would like to think Daenerys
would enjoy getting some form of payback
on your own - not only did he smashed a
big portion of her fleet but he also
took several of her allies prisoner can
you imagine if Daenerys sent all of her
remaining men to the city then she takes
both dragons and swoops out over the bay
and torches Euron's entire iron fleet
she could like the whole Bay on fire and
it would look incredible there is some
other news I want to talk about before I
end the video photos came out this week
and they showed nearly the entire cast
in the location where they filmed scenes
in the dragon pit
I believe the producers did invite some
of the cast to come out and celebrate
but they were definitely filming scenes
at the dragon pit while they were here
now there's no way to confirm which
characters were involved but I think
these scenes could have something to do
with Circe's downfall I know they could
always use it again for another parlay
scene but I just don't see them doing
that again
Cersei already lied once about sending
them help and we already know the city
does come under attack
I believe these scenes will take place
after King's Landing is destroyed the
capital will burn which will force them
to hold this little meeting right
outside of the city after Cersei is
killed and Dany has control of King's
Landing I think we might get some kind
of a victory speech in the dragon pit or
some kind of speech that gives hope for
the future
Daenerys could say something along the
lines of King's Landing no longer being
the capital of Westeros in the Iron
Throne no longer being the seat of power
essentially we could get another
breaking the wheel type of speech Jon
Snow could also say something here too
since this will take place at the end of
the season Jon might know about his true
parentage by now he should know that he
is the true heir to the Seven Kingdoms
but maybe he gives the speech about not
wanting to roll he has never appeared to
have the desire to want the world
Westeros and I think he will do what
maester aemon had done which is
basically refused to take the position
since the Narus Targaryen has always
wanted this maybe he gives the claim to
her or he just tells her that he wants
nothing to do with his claim or together
they could decide how they will make
Westeros prosper again there are just so
many different ways this could play out
but I think the dragon pit will be used
for a scene directly after King's
Landing Falls but this is just a guess
let me know what you think about these
most recent spoilers what could they be
using the dragon pit for again and do
you think it was dragon fire that burnt
the tops of the city walls put all your
comments down below anyways I really
appreciate all of you for stopping by to
watch the video I also want to thank
everyone that supports my channel on
patreon I cannot thank you all enough I
hope you have a great day I will see you
all again very soon bye
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]